did you know in Islam the obligation of
covering which is usually people feel
that email is actually ordered from God
two males first I am obliged to cover
from my navel to my knee did you know as
a Muslim if you harm a non-muslim in an
Islamic state it's as if you have harmed
the messenger peace be upon him did you
know in Islam that knowledge is
something which is valued and sacred the
first the first verses that were
revealed was if Quran which means read
and the first Institute University that
was established was by did you guys know
that in Islam you're not allowed to harm
an innocent person if you have an
innocent person is like you've harmed
and killed the whole of humanity as per
the Quran and the Prophet were happy is
your part of even went further to say
that you're not even allowed to cut down
trees did you know in Islam even smiling
is cherry did you know as a Muslim we
actually have to love and believe in
Jesus and his miraculous red birth and
if we don't then we aren't even
considered a Muslim
did you know Islam a polished racism a
millennium before the civil rights
movement the Prophet peace be upon him
and his last final sermon he mentions
that the Arab is no better than a non
Arab and the black is no better than a
white person and a white person who are
better than a black person the one who's
most closest to God is the one who was
in faith in the most did you know that
in Islam women have so many rights the
men actually encourage you really go out
of the way and take care of their women
the Prophet Mohammed is your instead the
best of you are those who are best to
their wives so much so that even if a
woman is a millionaire and the husband
is not the man is obligated to take care
of all her basic needs even her makeup
that's right he has to buy her Bobby
Brown huh Mac her benefit a nested ago
and guess what if he can't pay for it
because he's broke and she has all the
money in the world she still
penny yes masturbate the government has
to pay for her makeups that's because
the economic system also just they could
accommodate that
did you know Islam eradicated poverty as
Muslims were obliged to give 2.5 percent
of her annual savings to charity when
this happened in the past and this was
implemented no one was poor in the world
did you know Islam gives animal rights
that the perfectly speculum told us that
a woman who was walking past a thirsty
dog and gave her a bit of water was
forgiven for her sins and another woman
who was torturing a cat was bound to
Hellfire because of the ads that she did
was that cat
Oh